[Music]
in crafting the presidency
the constitution's architects imbued it
with independence unity
and the duty to faithfully execute the
laws
this was a radical departure from the
article's confederation which had no
separate executive responsible for the
government's administration
yet it was up to the first congress to
set up the executive branch
and the first congress affirmed the
convention's design by placing the
departments of foreign affairs war
and treasury under the president's
direction
and by stipulating that the president
had the sole authority to remove
executive officials they understood this
grant not as an act of legislative
discretion
but as mandated by the constitution's
language and logic
complicating the framers intention is
the unanticipated role that presidents
play
as leaders of their political parties in
the vast reach of modern government
ensuring the singular independent
executive is faithful and responsibly
administering
the government requires first a congress
that writes laws that are clear
and second is diligent in the oversight
of the executive
do you think the president has too much
authority over the federal government or
too little
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos
from aei